welcome back to CBS this morning former
President Bill Clinton and former
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton are
among those celebrating the life of
Congressman John Lewis today we spoke to
them yesterday exclusively about how
influenced them both as civil rights
activists and a friend during his more
than 30 years in Congress
I never was around a bigger and better
and I didn't want to do something that
made a difference
you called him the conscience of the
nation what do you mean by that
it was nearly killed in Selma and one or
two other times in Tennessee and he just
kept doing what he thought was right
a lot of people are hoping that the
Pettis bridge will be renamed to and
called the John Louis yes in 2000 I was
holding his hand walking across the
bridge on the 35th anniversary that
Hillary was a senator and the both of us
walked across with him and then he
walked across with President Obama he
was always there he was tired or full of
energy he was always there he showed up
to honor people and events
he believed in someone said about him he
never made you feel guilty he just made
you feel responsible do you think that's
a true characterization of him very good
when you first heard the news that we
had lost him what was your initial
thought you know it was such a sense of
both personal loss and a a sense of
national tragic loss especially at this
time Gail where his voice his moral
authority is so desperately needed it it
was such a joy of my life to be his
friend and I want to say something about
joy because we talked about his
incredible life of service and activism
and yes putting his life on the line but
he was a joyful man he was someone who
had
good time if you ever saw him dance he
had a big smile on his face he had a joy
just was contagious I like what
President Clinton said Madam Secretary
about him showing up because I think the
fact that he showed up at a book signing
for you I was so surprised smile on his
face that I love seeing I see how you
were doing
that's the kind of friend he was what
does this loss me to the country do you
think especially at this particular time
I think one of the things that I did
feel very grateful for having known him
for a long long time but that he lived
long enough to see the outpouring of
public support and to what happened to
George Floyd and all those other fine
people who were lost their lives finally
there was this galvanizing of opinion in
America Johnson himself was much broader
based and then what happened in the
sixties is civil rights here so I'm glad
he lived to see that and we need to
finish the work now yeah and here we sit
in the country right now we seem to be
going through two crises actually the
corona virus pandemic of course and now
the racial strife and racial injustice
that we're all feeling he spoke a lot
about getting into what he called good
trouble I love that phrase what does
that look like to both of you as we try
to move forward and heal during this
time I think we had to remember that the
great genius of John Lewis through all
of years in Congress and all those years
in civil rights movement was that he
knew how to make good trouble and he
knew how to heal it on troubled waters
that's a matter of heart as well as mind
and he was a genius Senate the rest of
us need to be searching for that perfect
fish TIA
thank you very much Clinton so number
one guys
their team said to me because I said
when was the last time they sat down and
did an interview together they said how
about a gazillion years but they were so
excited to sit and reminisce about John
Lewis they were in such everybody was in
such great spirits because that's what
John Lewis does for you he just makes
you feel good you know it's so hard to
process his loss but he left us with so
many wonderful things Bill Clinton told
a story that before he was going to
endorse him for a particular race he
said well I need you to do something
about environmental justice first he
always had words of advice for people he
never made you feel guilty he just made
you feel responsible yeah and he will be
dearly dearly and sorely missed Anthony
yeah I love that phrase you use Gail and
reminded me of something that the mayor
Andrew Young said which was that he
would he could break down barriers with
white people just with the sheer force
of his spirit we will to be talking to
ambassador Andrew Young in the next hour
yeah and as we think about what good
trouble means I'm reminded that by John
Lewis's own tally he was arrested more
than 40 times 40 of them in the 1960s
five after he was a member of Congress
make about that Congress yes and and
Tony he was willing to be arrested again
to I know again for something that he
believed in it 80 yes absolutely right